as a company Bud Light has essentially
gone into hiding ever since their
partnership with Womanhood cosplayer
Dylan Mulvaney was first announced they
put out a brief statement meekly
defending their decision but other than
that they've basically been silent uh
Bud light's Twitter account hasn't
tweeted anything since the controversy
began as the beer brand faces increasing
backlash and calls for boycotts in
summary the rollout for this marketing
campaign has been you might say less
than seamless and now we know who we can
thank for This brilliant idea or who Bud
Light can thank anyway although the
company has had very little to defend
their Mulvaney endorsement deals since
the deal was made public we only need to
go back a few days before the
announcement to get a more in-depth
defense an explanation of it a couple of
weeks ago the vice president of Bud
Light a woman named Alyssa heinershine
appeared on on a obscure YouTube podcast
called make yourself at home and there
she went into great depth about her
experience being Bud light's first
female VP something she's very proud of
and about Midway through the
conversation she begins to explain the
marketing shift that she is Engineering
in the company this is an effort to be
more inclusive and more quote-unquote
representative here's the piece of that
discussion that has since gone viral
listen
I'm a businesswoman I had a really clear
job to do when I took over Bud Light and
it was this brand is in Decline it's
been in Decline for a really long time
and if we do not attract young drinkers
to come and drink this brand there will
be no future for Bud Light so I had this
super clear mandate it's like we need to
evolve and Elevate this incredibly
iconic brand and my what I brought to
that was a belief in okay what is what
what does evolve and elevate mean it
means inclusivity it means Shifting the
tone it means having a campaign that's
truly inclusive and feels lighter and
brighter and different and appeals to
women and to men and representation is
it sort of the heart of evolution you've
got to see people who reflect you in the
work and we had this hangover I mean Bud
Light had been kind of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
so we see we see right away from the
outset this woman has of course
completely misdiagnosed the problem yes
Bud Light sales and market share have
been declining over the years but she's
somehow determined that the waning
interest in the brand is due to its frat
boy image you know customers have
stopped drinking Bud Light Alyssa
decided because they're concerned about
its toxic masculinity and its
insufficient focus on diversity and
Equity so she imagines a scenario where
the once typical Bud Light Drinker you
know is at the liquor store scanning the
options at the store of all the
different beers uh almost reaches for
the Bud Light 30 pack but then pulls
back and says to himself never mind I'm
only buying beer from companies that
have displayed an outward commitment to
inclusivity and representation then she
imagines the consumer going up to the
cashier and asking where they keep their
trans affirming beverage options
but you know I can't say for sure that
that scenario has never played out
anywhere on Earth
but this is not exactly how it typically
works in the real world the truth is
that Bud Light is declining because the
product is terrible first of all and
people have other options you know it
tastes like carbonated tap water
flavored with notes of old hay shoveled
off the floor of somebody's barn and
that's why it's not selling as well
anymore you know before the explosion of
the The Craft Beer Market people drank
Anheuser-Busch products because they
were forced basically they're forced to
they're forced to choose between
um that brand of piss water or some
other brand of piss water most beer
drinkers didn't even know back in those
days back in the old Dark Ages what beer
was supposed to actually taste like they
didn't know until the proliferation of
craft beer and ipas and now consumers
can pay three or four dollars more for
real beer
the effect on Bud Light sales it's
similar to the effect on what the effect
on Outback Steakhouse would be if a
restaurant that actually knows how to
cook a steak moved in right next door
and only charged a couple of dollars
extra just a very bad situation
meanwhile compounding Bud light's
problems is that the fact that sales of
beer in general all types
have dipped in recent years as many
younger people unfortunately choose to
smoke weed instead so all told Bud Light
is facing many challenges and many
Challengers and increasingly it's losing
that contest that's the real problem but
it's not the problem that Alyssa
heinershine wants to solve for her the
the only problem that she'll ever
recognize when it comes to Bud Light or
anything else is insufficient wokeness
if you ever read the defined print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer or School your internet service
provider kind of defeats the purpose you
would think so to actually stop people
from monitoring your online activity you
need to do what I do and use expressvpn
think about all the times you've used
Wi-Fi at a coffee shop Hotel even a
friend's house without expressvpn every
site you visit can be logged by the
Admin of that Network it's still true
even when you're in incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your online online activity stays
private expressvpn works on all your
devices and it's super easy to use the
app has one button you tap the button
and you're in it's really that simple so
stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show use my
Link at expressdpn.com Matt walshow to
get three extra months free that's exp
resvpn.com Matt Walsh show
to continue watching one more minute of
this interview the clip we just watched
is the bit that went viral but if you go
to the YouTube channel and you look at
the actual um
interview that it continues on this part
of the conversation continues on for
another minute and you hear something
that I think is is kind of important uh
listen to this
long story short Super Bowl spot fast
forward
I cast an incredible female
choreographer who just brought
incredibly positive amazing energy to
the spot we cast Miles Teller and his
wife Kelly teller but it was really
crucial to me that if you see that spot
Kelly is
Kelly is the heartbeat of that spot
you're seeing this whole experience
through Kelly she's the beating heart
she I would sort of argue is sort of
what propels you through that experience
and and that was intentional
um and then we had another really fun
spot first spot out of the gate was the
first time ever we'd had a female
protagonist in this really cool she was
sort of cool as hell bobbin and weaving
through a bar but anyway listen I'm not
going to pretend that there isn't so
much more work to do from a business
results perspective and of course from a
representation perspective but I feel
like you
you have to put your money where your
mouth is when you're trying to evolve a
brand and elevate it and bring in new
consumers so that's been incredibly
important to me
so there she's explaining the thought
process behind Bud light's most recent
Super Bowl ad Campaign which did not
feature Dylan Mulvaney that commercial
the one she's referring to is the one
where the actor Miles Teller uh comes in
the room and and dances with his wife to
while she's listening to hold music
that's what the commercial is here's
here's like 10 seconds I could watch
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
okay now the interesting thing is that
if anyone had watched that ad when it
first aired
and then complained that it was woke
you know they would have been mocked for
it they would have been treated as a
paranoid conspiracy theorist if they had
claimed that the Bud Light Super Bowl ad
uh that that one where they're dancing
to hold music had a liberal bias if
anyone had said that
after all just a commercial with two
people dancing in their living rooms
what's woke about that and yet she
proudly admits that she chose that ad
because it helps further her agenda to
feminize the company and bring it into
alignment with her left-wing values it
was just done in that case in a
relatively subtle way and that's always
more clever when they make a little bit
more subtle
and that's going to be more you know
then you have the subtle messaging which
gets into people's minds without them
even realizing but also they put
themselves in a position where if anyone
who's slightly perceptive notices what
they're doing and says it out loud
everyone else could say what are you
talking about don't be ridiculous
There's No Agenda here
except there is they'll tell you
the Dylan Mulvaney sponsorship was on
the other hand far less subtle and now
they're paying the price for really just
a lack of subtlety except that from vice
president Alyssa's perspective they're
not paying a price at all because she
obviously is not really concerned with
Bud light's Health as a company or its
sales or it's long-term prospects
she almost certainly doesn't even like
the product probably hasn't had a single
sip of it in her life you could work at
a liquor store for 30 years and never
once see someone who looks like Alyssa
heinershide or has a name like Alyssa
heiner should walk up to the calendar
with a six pack of Bud Light I'm not
sure if I've ever seen a woman drink Bud
Light ever in my entire life
she doesn't like the product she doesn't
like the company she doesn't like the
customer base
she has yet another liberal woman put
into a position of power within an
institution
despite not understanding the
fundamental point of that institution
and hating whatever she does understand
about it
yeah we've discussed in depth why these
companies go woke why almost every major
company goes well cars are already gone
woke long long ago and all those points
still stand but here's another reason
just as pertinent
every institution in our country is
being taken over by people who hate the
institutions they're in charge of
this is true in the corporate world this
is true in government
this is especially true in the military
this is true in many of our churches
this is true even down to the level of
the family which is the most fundamental
societal institution where many families
are led by mothers and fathers who have
no interest in marriage or in parenting
they treat their children like pets or
fashion accessories hence the
proliferation of quote unquote trans
kids
so across the Spectrum you find
institutions
that aren't really uh collapsing you
know from any pressure from without so
much as imploding it's a controlled
demolition
an intentional Act of sabotage from
within
Bud Light is just one example certainly
not the most significant or important
it's a symptom of an underlying thing
and it's no surprise to see this
happening as the left seizes hold of the
culture hatred of societal institutions
has always been one of the essential
animating principles of the left
and self-hatred too
now as I've said before leftism is a
religion of self-loathing teaches boys
to hate their masculinity it teaches
girls to hate their femininity it
teaches white people to hate their race
it teaches Americans to hate their
country it teaches westerners to hate
their history and Heritage and so on
that's where you find the kind of
engineered self-loathing at its deepest
levels
closer to the surface is Bud Light and
all other woke corporations managed by
Executives who hate the companies they
run and especially hate the customers
that they serve
and hopefully at least now that feeling
will be mutual
and I'll do it for the show today or for
this part of the show anyways we'll go
over to the members block and become a
member today by using Code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]